I need to leave 30 to 45 minutes on either side of homeopathic radiation drops, avoiding
mint and caffeine, etc. I wouldn't say 30 to 45 minutes. I'd say 15 to 30 minutes. Yes,
that's why I typically recommend people to take them at night before you go to bed or right
away in the morning, but you're going to have to time your teeth brushing because most people
have mint in their toothpaste. Binders, so a lot of people are taking binders, biding agents, and I
tell them to take that 30 minutes away from other food. Binders, mint is not going to bother a
bider, okay? So if you're taking a biotoxin bider, HM, ET bider, or whatever, that's mint is not
going to affect that mint, spearmint, peppermint affects homeopathics, not biders. So you don't have to
worry about your teeth brushing thing with a bider, but with homeopathic drops, yes, you don't have to
worry about those things. Don't worry about them. Just don't do it.